we're gonna zip through this so let's
see how well we do
you may also like to draw for yourself
um a tan curve we're eventually gonna
draw all of them but this will be the
first one
and you may notice i have all this extra
space over here on the right hand side
of my gram
and that's on purpose so you probably
want to make your
plane the width of your page but don't
use the whole width
just have some space extra left over
okay so
you might want to get a friend to help
you with that you might have more
success
hey it's nice to see you too
general solution
is just a way of writing your answers
that's it full stop
okay so remember so far we've been
looking at t results right
and auxiliary angle i don't know if
you're getting sick to death of me
telling you
what these are and what they're about
and how they relate to this when i
remember going through three unit
um i sort of got these as different
things and
i sort of understood by the time the
exam came around how to do each one
but i didn't understand any of their
relationships with each other so i
didn't know if that means
i was fully taught or i was just asleep
at the time but
i'm saying it like five to ten times
just so that eventually
one of them will sink in so these two
methods
are about changing the way a problem is
written so you can solve it
right turning it to something we're
already familiar with this has nothing
to do despite the name
with actually solving questions it's
just about how do you
write out and express articulate the
answer you do get
after you've done t results or auxiliary
angle or like a simpler type of question
which you don't need to rephrase in that
way
okay so to draw out the way it works
let's consider
just a nice simple equation like tan
x is equal to one okay tan x is equal to
one
now ordinarily we would get supplied a
domain
with this kind of question for instance
because you guys voted for radians
no it's a 2 pi that's pretty standard
okay now
tell me again remind me why is it that
we treat
equations like this you have to get
supplied with the domain why is that
okay good there are many solutions this
equation not just
many there's an infinite number right
which is different to say
quadratics or cubics or other kind of
polynomials you've got there might be
many solutions but there's still
a finite number okay the problem here is
if you don't restrict the domain in some
way
and say i just want these specific
solutions you're going to be writing
them forever
so that's why i've got over here this is
not a two pi
okay so i've got pi in there two pi here
and i've got
two asymptotes
all right so that's how i used to right
now tan x is equal to one
uh i've drawn my graph in there just so
we can illustrate this
um visually as well as algebraically
okay
what kind of solutions am i expecting
well something like this
that's very straight if i draw in the
line y equals one
okay in this domain that we've chosen
i'm expecting two solutions
right namely here and
here okay now we're pretty good with our
exact values at least for simple ones
like this
what angle are we expecting for the
first solution
time four thank you and you know i've
sort of
i've sort of dropped your trolls i've
sort of drawn my graph well enough
to you there's plan two that's about
half okay so
one of them is pi on four okay
and the next solution
is pi radians that way right namely
5.4 okay
so we would say there's our solution
in this restricted domain okay
but the fact that we've got these two
solutions actually means because
tree graphs are so uh repetitive we call
them periodic right
so they've got a period and they repeat
again and again and again we can
actually take advantage of this to not
just write these two solutions but
all the solutions or at least some of
them until we can see a pattern
right so if i extend my graph a little
bit
including this um this y equals one line
let's take it all the way over here and
let's see how much space i'll have
graphs
i'll have i'll be able to go on okay
so let's see here
okay so i've got at least enough space
for another
two copies of the graph okay so it looks
to me like i'm heading all the way up to
four pi
that's three pi okay
so i can see another two solutions right
pi and four five pi over four next one
will be
nine pound four we're on the ball today
we're good at fractions i can add
fractions
the last one
yeah yeah it's a shame it's lucky if
you've already written your report okay
so there's my
here's my four answers okay five four
five point four
nine and thirteen okay so let's just
list these out here
what i'm gonna do is for this next part
of the answer i'm gonna
ditch this restriction okay um so i'm
gonna say pine four
five 5 4
9 13
and so on i could keep going and this
domain is
well i'm looking at all of them really
okay if i want to be really correct i
also ought to have
not just three dots at the end but three
dots at the beginning
because they also go in an introduction
that way
okay so all of these solutions right
because they're so
orderly right i should be able to get
some kind of expression that puts all of
these together
right rather than listing them all out
okay so what these all have in common
well to get from one solution to the
next one
because of the shape of tan and the way
its period works right i could really
write this as
part 4 right then my next one is palm 4
plus pi i added that because that's the
p
right and the next one is pi 4 plus 2 pi
and so on right
okay so what's a better way to write
this than actually
to write out every single option well i
can sort of
get it generalize and say look here's an
expression
you'll cover all of them okay it looks
like every single one has palm four in
it
right that's kind of like your your
related angle right so i'm gonna have a
pi
and then what do i add on well
zero lots of pie one lot of pie two lots
of pie
just integer bunches right
so to sort of summarize it together
let's call it
empire where and you have to specify
this by the way
where and is an integer now this is
where all of those
hours laboring over set notation like
why are we learning this okay
um are going to be worth it because you
have to write this so many times
that to write where n is an integer is
going to be whole hours of your life
that you will never get back so instead
use set notation okay that's a
faster way to write than on than saying
n is
you'd be surprised you're going to be
writing this a lot sometimes you're
going to write it multiple times per
question
okay so yeah question fancy like that ah
no
but you do you don't have to write fancy
but you do have to introduce
um this this letter if you're gonna talk
about it right
um you have to just it can't just pop up
out of nowhere a wild end appears
okay um and you also have to not just
introduce it but you've got to qualify
it right you've got to say it's an
integer
so most of you will find you'll start
writing this in textbooks write it like
that as well so
you sort of might as well get used to it
okay all right
any questions before i move on
no because zed right
um that funky looking zen is actually
the name for a whole set right
so it's not it's it's the set of you
know zero
one two three actually it goes the other
way too
minus one minus two and so on so
it wouldn't make sense to put the z here
because i want this to be a number
i want it to be one or two or three or
four i don't want it to be every single
one all at the same time
okay all right so
this is what we call this is the general
solution
okay for this equation that we started
with
sorry okay is that all right so before
we leave off
um this example and i wonder if you can
see why i picked out tan first okay
let's just consider some different
result say tan x is equal to
two okay so just keep it simple okay
tan x is equal to two now this is not an
exact value right
and if i draw in my tan x equals sorry
my y equals the two line
okay you can see i'm still going to get
the same solutions
right it's just that the amount that
they moved over
which here we call pineapple right the
amount they moved over is all just a
little extra
can you see that they all can shift a
bit further so
it's still going to be in this form it's
still going to be something plus
empire right something
plus n pi where
and an integer so to work out the
something get your calculator out
and um we're in we're in radiance right
so make sure you're in the right mode
which i'm not and because 10 x equal to
2 right
where did we get this part 4 from before
it was
the angle that satisfies the equation
the first one okay
so the same way you're gonna do tan
inverse of two
right that'll give you the angle that
satisfies that which i think i heard it
was one point
let's do it to let's do it to two
decimal places is
um fine so that's one point one one okay
so one of the other benefits of of doing
it in radians you don't have to put
units on there because we assume it
really so i suppose i should put
approximately
okay so it's going to be that angle
that's our substitute for one for pi and
four
okay plus you're in pi and every time
you're going to get a new solution
every time you increment up you know 1
pi 2 pi 3 pi 4 pi
and it works for negative values of n as
well because if i drew backwards okay
you'd keep on going
pi radians each time okay
all right now i just introduced it for
tan
what i want you to think about for the
next five minutes is
this is what the general solution for
tan looks like what would it look like
i'm doing this in a very specific order
what would it look like because i'll
give you a clue
okay well not so much a clue as a tip we
we developed
the general solution okay by by graphing
it out and seeing how it worked that
each time you just move forward higher
okay now with cosine it's not same with
sine it's not the same either okay
they're all different
my tip is to draw it first solve it for
something simple
like we did we picked 10x equals one i
picked it because it gave you nice
angles pick something else
okay something nice and i'm not too
complicated so you can focus on how it
works
around the individual numbers see if you
can come up with a
general solution for cosine i'll give
you about five minutes to think about it